why comes from the past it's an origin
story as an individual our personal why
is it's our birthright every single
person has one and there's only one and
it is borne out of how we were raised
and the values that were instilled in us
that made us who we are and the rest of
our lives offering us an opportunity to
live in balance with our why or not
everybody has a why every company has a
why it's basically the origin story
right
Bill Gates his obsession with finding
more productive ways to do things when
he was young became the why of Microsoft
and the company was obsessed with
helping people be more productive right
which is why Apple kept their thing very
small and we had four or five percent of
the world's computer operating systems
and Microsoft had 96 percent because
that's a great visionary thing for
people we all want to be more productive
right we don't all want to challenge the
status quo right adjust cause is the
future it just causes about where we're
going the the why is a hundred percent
objective you don't get to decide what
your why is it is what it is you are who
you are your culture is your culture but
your just cause you get to determine
what cause you'd like to be a part of
what cause you'd like to devote your
your life or your career to help build
and by the way you can have multiple
just causes you can have one for your
career one for your family one for for
church right you can be a part of many
just causes and where where a lot of
especially young people put a lot of
pressure on themselves of what's your
vision you don't have to come up with
your own vision you can attach yourself
to somebody else's vision you have to
find a vision not everybody is visionary
like Jobs or gates right there's only a
small percentage of our population that
that we would call visionary but we can
attach ourselves to their vision and
make their vision ours right go read the
original vision that Gates put out it's
amazing and he's consistent when he gave
his TED talk about the Gates Foundation
and ending malaria in the world it's the
same vision he's just doing it through a
different means now before it was
technology now it's through mosquito
nets but the language was exactly the
same so you have to find a vision for
sure for sure so the question is how do
you build a just cause a has somebody
else already articulated it for you that
you're like ooh love the world that
they're trying to build
right we want to do that we're gonna
devote our company to doing that my
vision is to create a world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspire to go to work
feel safe when they're there and return
home fulfilled at the end of the day
that's what I've devoted my career to
anybody wants to join me come join me
why do you think I do these talks I do
these talks because I'm looking to
spread the gospel I'm looking to share
tools with anybody who might think that
that's kind of interesting and I need
you guys to do it I'm just I'm just a
guy with a with a you know with with a
microphone that's it right but you're
actually building the companies that are
going to create the cultures that are
more likely to create the world I
imagine we need each other that's why I
do these things looking for the army
right so you can find a vision of the
visions about where you're going and
it's an ideal you'll never actually get
there but you'll die trying which is the
point
[Music]
[Music]